alrights Wednesday we're back and got
into package today from chef Marcus this
is I'm so excited for for good movies
that check this out check it out blue
red The Raven yeah where he plays Edgar
Allen Poe I saw that a long time ago I
haven't seen that one yeah it's pretty
good actually I haven't seen that one
either I have not seen this one all
right so I'm excited probably good
here's a little classic I haven't seen
it I haven't seen this one either
Dante's Inferno yes checks are Tracy and
this one I'm very excited about the
Gormenghast haven't seen it yeah this is
like because I've read all the books
you've got so I read the trilogy and I'm
very excited I don't think I've seen
that BBC miniseries of it okay it's on
it so we got all kind of fun [ __ ] yeah
we'll definitely talk about them when we
watch them oh yeah yeah thanks Marcus
yeah thank you very much we'll get up
we'll get right on now that's pretty
cool and then what else we got going on
today I have to mention remember on
yesterday's show when I said about the
people that had the kitty and the baby
stroller yeah you saw him again well
they they haven't started walking yet
because I was just getting back and I
guess they don't live in this
neighborhood because they were parked in
the parking lot like at the trailhead
and I saw like the guy getting the
stroller out of the trunk
and I was like that looks like the same
troller because it was blue I know she
wants to finally I didn't recognize the
guy but I was like well he looked like
an older guy like I knew he had like he
was tall Aeneid gray hair and and then I
so I kind of slowed down and watched and
then the the wife got out of the front
seat with the kitty she's gonna be
pushing around damn stroller okay [ __ ]
you it's it well I looked it up
afterwards but you don't want for those
things I don't know I don't remember how
much it was they have like a bunch of
different ones cuz I was like they gotta
have like pet strollers they have
everything for pets nowadays and they do
they do have ones that are like all
closed in know like netting and I was
like we would probably need that because
otherwise would be like let me yeah yeah
cuz she just jump out if we had one with
a hole in it no I'd have to be covered
up yeah what else is going on anything
anything not I don't think there's any
all that much going on we just like
recorded some
[ __ ] for the men Asia start streaming
soon we're gonna get on that streaming
what we should do is we should decide
like we can do it like maybe two nights
a week or something like that and we'll
and it'll be the same night in the same
time so then people will know right to
tune in so we don't have to like keep
saying a lot of people that do it just
do it at the drop of a hat I don't know
Ron and to give it to give a notice you
know what I mean it happens when it
happens you could just do it that way
like I just do it we could wind it
happens when it happens yeah
get out well I don't you know and it
doesn't matter because after you get
done with a stream it goes up anyway
yeah no it's not like they miss it
that's true all right we'll see but yeah
that is definitely something a lot
consider doing oh I see what else going
on but like I said we'll only do it a
couple the news says the earth is
falling apart World's End and I don't
give a [ __ ] now I give a [ __ ] well even
if you did give a [ __ ] there's nothing
you know looks like it looks like half
the damn people want the world to end
the other half are trying to [ __ ] put
it back the way it was or whatever I
don't know okay but they're fighting
over it you know what is this and I
think that this is just how it has to be
I'm talking about that what's gonna
happen has to happen in order for it to
shake yourself out yeah yeah and I mean
no stopping it no well yeah like this is
this is not something that one person
could yeah people want [ __ ]
everything walked [ __ ] economy to
collapse and then it will collapse and
the ones that wanted to collapse like
the first ones to get killed when it
does I mean yeah just gonna say yeah
well like I said I don't you know their
[ __ ] there well there's too many people
and there's too many factors and it's
like so I don't really see the point in
like worrying about [ __ ] like I said
it's not Lauren there's nothing I can do
about it not really worried about it
anymore I'm just watching it yeah and
reporting on it you know no mean people
out there wanted out you know and I'm
just saying better cover your own ass
don't trust Dinis people well I don't
yeah I don't trust him but yeah so what
else
oh we've gotten like a [ __ ] ton of
requests for various topics to do some
of these might take longer than others
to get to you but we'll probably end up
getting to him somebody wanted us to do
a show on the black monk of Pontefract
which is a poltergeist case which I we
did I wrote about that in my book I
don't think we've done that one actually
that we did a special we might have
mentioned it um you know like maybe when
we were doing conspiratorial or like
another a paranormal show or something
like if somebody asked me about that
case because that's kind of a famous one
I think we did it on a holiday special
see I don't I'd have to go back I don't
remember back and do it but I mean I did
we did do the UM the black mausoleum or
whatever that is like I think that's in
Edinburgh yeah the one that's supposed
to be like the the poltergeist thing
that haunted tomb or whatever the price
is a house the problem with a lot of the
real famous cases is that the more you
investigated the more you find out
there's not much there well yeah and
that it's around some kind of a location
that started off as a damn tourist site
to begin with and then the reports or
just you can't verify them because there
weren't enough witnesses or the reports
are from so long ago you can't check on
it yeah you know that's a lot of the
problems like remember the that one time
they covered the cases of the the damn
coffins that were moving around yeah
yeah but then it turned out there was it
really wasn't me anything to that yeah I
don't remember what was causing that
people going in and out and moving it
over over the years and then nobody's
really nobody was really sure about what
the arrangement was the prior
arrangement anyway you know they didn't
know there's no way to prove the
original arrangement to the [ __ ]
coffins to begin with yeah I can't
remember like I remember I was doing a
show about that but it was a really long
time long I can't remember I know there
was like some really like simple X is a
simple explanation but and then some of
the stuff was based upon like little
articles that were written and then the
guy who is claiming to have seen this he
can pretty much verify he
never even went to that Island yeah yeah
there was a bunch of stuff that [ __ ]
like that
and there's stuff you know a lot of that
kind of stuff you know paranormal and
everything is you know a lot of the
information is secondhand third-hand and
old and then it just gets passed on over
and over again until you know it becomes
more now I had that poltergeist thing go
down in in in Mammoth and with the
technology of the day back then there
was no way to record it other than
taking a few snapshots of Polaroid
camera yeah and then all your in and up
with there's a couple of items on the
ground yeah you know something upside
down with a [ __ ] towel folded over
you know I mean how is that prove that
happened right yeah y'all have a video
camera now right you know it would
actively defy your attempts at trying to
catch it yeah doing stuff it did things
when it wanted to when you're out of the
corner of your eye when your back was
turned
yeah or when you it was happening in
other rooms you walk in to stop and you
see the furniture arranged differently
you know now one of the few things that
was seen in actual motion I didn't see
it below us in red did was when the damn
two things happened at once pillows
jumped up off a bed that they were
looking at went over their head and went
up went on top of the damn sliding glass
and it was exactly in the sliding doors
of the closet it was a closet just like
that it has some above it yeah they went
up there and when as that happened the
comforters slid off and wrapped around
their feet and it happened fast
yeah the lowest said it just lifted up
and came off like a manta ray like it
slipped off the I heard I heard her
scream and I ran in and I saw it you
know the results but yeah I didn't see
it they said they did well it's really
weird a lot of cases that I wrote about
in this and you said this happened too
is that very very rarely do you is
anybody looking directly at the [ __ ]
yeah it's almost like he can't move it
while you're looking directly at it but
it doesn't really seem to make sense
though because some of the stuff I
looked directly at like like the damn
rocking the rocking chair yeah I saw
that rock and with the Biggles you
didn't start though not in see it start
yes sir and you saw it once it was as
soon as I looked at it it was rocking
and then it came to it came to a halt I
was
running away yeah you know that I mean
it was frozen we'll look for a few
seconds to see what was going on and
then I ran from it yeah Liana and leave
in a sauce like a some kind of
distortion on the back let me know where
the headrest type it where the backrest
is yeah so like a little distortion like
lift up and going to go away into the
damn corner it was weird look like a
little Mirage kinda yeah like kind of
like a heat Mirage like ER yeah yeah I
can air yeah I call it a mirage like you
know when you're looking at monkey waves
yeah you're looking down across the
street like what it's really look kind
of like that except it was prior I don't
know about the size of a baseball I
guess and as it kind of moved away it
kind of left a trail behind it yeah yeah
the only way I can describe it happened
fast
yeah so well-read saw it too I mean the
same thing happened here when that
remote control and flying off the table
yeah no one was looking directly at it I
didn't see it until it was already
flying I was looking over the top of it
but I was just kind of yeah it's just
like underneath a line of vision I was
in a kind of a stupor yeah like how you
know he's owned out yeah
like when your stare was like that and
then you guys reacted to it and then I
kind of had to snap out of it yeah
because I realized for cuz I realized I
was like wait did dodges jump off the
table to look at it and then I looked
down and there was a stack of coins at
my feet yeah yeah that's weird that is
pretty weird so and it's not a ghostly
phenomena you you've seen it it's it's
definitely paranormal but I think it's
our spk recurrent spontaneous oh yeah I
didn't get like I didn't get a sense of
like oh there's somebody here doing that
like a like a ghost doing that I just
got I had the sense that you did it yeah
I didn't have a feeling of presence no I
didn't either
but I did back in Mammoth yeah annex and
and Jen Demetri as they kind of got
upset over it I could feel the hair Stan
on the back of my neck feel it kind of
like it was coming back cuz Demetri
wanted you to do it he's like Tom do it
again do it again I could feel it coming
back but then I I don't know I kind of
chickened out I guess
well cuz you weren't really sure what
the day before it it had done something
it had torn off that piece of molding on
top oh yeah in the kitchen in the
kitchen and fries yeah oh yeah so you
know I thought maybe it'd be more
violent this time yeah it might have
been because you said that you know
something watching you though when I
went back in - yeah like it that was
like a little while later like after cuz
I had to go back in the room like to get
something or like to go to the bathroom
or something like that and then I kind
of got creeped out but just for a second
yeah you know that was a weird time that
that was all happy that's because it
seemed like a lot of that kind of stuff
was going on went on for about what two
months maybe yeah something like off and
on but it was it was nowhere it didn't
have anywhere near the the the
occurrence II you know I'm never like
the recurrence yeah of it of it was just
every now and every now and then one
time I just got she woke me up out of a
[ __ ] dead sleep so he's at the door
never that yeah it was like it was like
4:00 in the morning it was almost 4:00
in the morning and I heard the doorbell
yeah I was pretty she said she heard it
twice yeah and see that's the thing cuz
I've been kind of half awake I heard the
doorbell it's 4:00 in the morning and I
woke up and then I'm like laying there
for about 1530 seconds and I'm like did
I just hear that or did I imagine it but
then it rang again and I was awake cuz I
wasn't gonna wake you up cuz I thought
oh well maybe I just dreamed it even
though I was pretty sure I heard it but
then I was just like laying there and I
was wide awake and then I heard it again
yeah then I woke you up I'll put my
sweatpants on and grab my [ __ ] he yes
with my piece of [ __ ] well I didn't know
I thought it was a person
yeah like spunky's ring at the doorbell
at 4:00 in the morning very very unusual
and I went and looked at that front door
and we have glass doors yeah there was
nobody there
yeah like glass panes in the middle
there's there's um shades over them but
I did they were open it's but I think
they were open and I'm and I'm looking
I don't see anybody standing in there so
that's kind of tactically can't creep
around you know go through the corners
and looking out through the front window
didn't see anything and then the garage
door opened up the middle of the night
that was that yeah wouldn't it yeah was
that the same night or the know what the
same guy I think this might have been
well the creepy thing about that was
that the garage door opened and you
could almost like have plausible
deniability about that because it's like
maybe somebody's thing is on the same
frequency as yours or whatever but the
weird thing about that is that when you
went in there to check on it and I came
in after and the door from the laundry
room into the garage open opened by
itself in word that's right and it
doesn't do that like it swings yeah you
were with me right yeah it swings and
closes like you can't leave it you have
to like prop it open and then another
thing that was weird that happened is
when a wind there was a wind outside and
and I could feel a wind blowing inside
the house a little bit yeah and I walked
out into the living room and saw Badgers
the cat sitting there looking at the
back door and the back door was wide
open but it was still locked with the
deadbolt that was never that heard that
happened like yeah in the morning
because I got up and I I was going to
work yeah I said Jenny why did you leave
the door open and I was like why we
don't ever open that door ever door was
what yeah we never opened that door the
door was it's it's a double glass door
that has dead bolts and stuff that opens
up to the back patio yeah it's like
right across from why don't ever use it
it was wide open just one side of the
door yeah and the deadbolt with a little
count that was weird yeah because like I
I was going out cuz I was going to work
and I was like why the [ __ ] is that door
open yeah this went on for about two
months all in the period there's a bunch
of other [ __ ] that happened to it I was
playing damn [ __ ] video games this
and felt a disturbance off to my right
and saw that damn measuring glass for
eliquid fall through fall down and hit
the bottom shelf POW through the lake it
way through the show but the only way
couldn't have come out and went down and
went back in it's like it felt through
all the shelves yes and it was shot down
and when it hit went and rattled on its
bottom yeah I press pause I walked over
there and looked at that I did get that
kind of like yeah a hair stand up
feeling he knows like oh [ __ ] yeah
that's some creepy [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ]
get off and that was around the time
where me and you were getting ready to
go out and I grabbed that DVD walked up
the DVD player in the damn drawer I
didn't oh [ __ ]
like it knew that you wanted to put it
and during that whole [ __ ] during
that whole period remember how weird
that TV was acting it would it turned
itself on all things would turn itself
off all the time and in the the cable
dude came and I says this thing keeps
turning on by itself and he's like yeah
you got doing it and I was like no I was
like why would the cabbage and he says
there's no reason why this TV should
just turn on what so this is it I said
yeah we did we asked the cable guy he
was there for something else I asked him
he's like no but we just it would just
be on all the time it would be on a
screensaver not on a channel yeah you
know some kind of screen and it's a you
have to realize it's like we have you
know we have a TV in our bedroom
there's a TV in the living room that we
never walk we hardly ever watch it I
mean it's never on gasps [ __ ] yeah it's
just like if guests come over and like
everybody wants to sit in the living
room watch some [ __ ] but we don't ever
watch it it'll be like a year right
behind it is the little tower for the
for the for the broke the Wi-Fi Wi-Fi
and it's all part of that same service
to cable on the Wi-Fi I don't really
know how it works I don't watch any of
it the cables almost for damn free
they try to give us movie channels I
don't watch that [ __ ] yeah um but I
don't know they just find that TV on
it's just mysterious for a while it was
like every morning like I would come out
like this was when I had to get up early
and I would like be going to you know
commuting to work and I would get up and
I'm like that [ __ ] TV is on again it
was on like every [ __ ] morning yeah
we changed out and got another
television it would do it again and it's
tilted so one the TV now this is the
third TV I think that happens when I
talk about it yeah never
it would yes so now now that we wanna
talk about it little tomorrow morning it
will probably be on when I get up I
betcha and this period was going on
during the time that she was writing
math mom yeah and I was she was asking
me questions and I was told we were
talking about it all and we were and we
were talking to red and Louis on the
phone all the time
[ __ ] like that so it was like we were
always and we were talking to Steve Mara
all the time and like yeah
it we were talking poltergeist like all
the time and Louis and red were kind of
wrapped up in kind of this kind of a
weird Christian Gnostic [ __ ] will the
spirits and God and demons and you know
and and I'm just going like no because
it still does it over here yeah well
then it's watching you know I didn't
feel like particularly threatened by it
it's kind of creepy I mean it's creepy
too it's nowhere near as strong as it
was to see a door like open by itself or
like here the doorknob or like fine
doors open that shouldn't be open some
about some about hormones when you're
like 13 or 14 and you don't you've never
heard of of a poltergeist or are spk or
anything or anything like that it's it's
more frequent it's stronger and it kinda
has a more menacing aura to it yeah and
it kind of mimics or responds to you if
you get scared it starts becoming a
little more scary yeah if you think it's
funny it starts doing things that are a
little bit funny started playing little
games yeah if you chill out it'll start
acting up a lot if you get real scared
and shut the [ __ ] down into vanish yeah
it's that is almost like a fail-safe
yeah too freaked out it'll just shut
down and it'll stop yeah but it'll come
back yeah cuz you'll be thinking about
it again well yeah and it'll slowly
start off small again and build back up
and it'll throw things and it'll do
things in front of witnesses that we'll
see cuz we haven't really been talking
about it for a while but it's like since
we just started talking about today I
now wonder if but um
creepy shits gonna
Demitri over and they saw it and they
were just like so it's true remember
that because they knew about the air but
I mean I think they had read they
thought they were kind of bullshitting
yeah maybe and you know if I could if I
could make that [ __ ] happen in a
controlled environment you know with a
bunch of scientists around I would but I
know I know it wouldn't happen yeah
because it'd be just like trying to take
a piss oh so you watch it and it's not
something you could use I don't think
like you know like the Jedi are using
this [ __ ] yeah I don't think so it's
something I think you have to be pretty
certain state of mind and you can't
depend on it and you have to have
plausible deniability it's not something
you can force
I mean I can see why you know if there
was a possibility that you could do that
you can see why like governments and
such would want to look into that
because [ __ ] if you could like have some
assassins you can like kill people at a
distance they tried it though yeah I
know but it didn't work the army had had
programs so the only one that kind of
had was the bisque on avaiable was one
called Stargate yeah when they were
trying to do remote viewing and a couple
of the Rope viewers had good success not
had spontaneous astral projection which
is different than remote viewing a lot
stronger remote viewing as more of Mike
might be a statistical anomaly I kind of
feel like it probably is cuz they're not
feeling they're not I don't feel like
they're there yeah
yeah I mean I felt like I was there yeah
yeah and evidently some the person a
person is there could feel that you're
there so you become a living ghost yeah
like a forest ghost they couldn't see me
evidently yeah but they were but they
were freaked out they wouldn't tell me
exactly what it was it was just I think
it the way he reacted that feeling a
presence of something watching you it's
probably what it was yeah and I he did
confirm that it was up from the ceiling
and that's where I was seeing him from
yeah but I don't think he actually saw
it I think he just detected he was being
watched
yeah he just probably felt that because
you do feel like that when people are
looking at you so when you feel it when
it starts kicking off it's not me
consciously seeing you yeah I'm aspect
of my unconscious mind
yeah that's seeing you yeah I mean most
of us is unconscious not conscious
people think that they're conscious
waking self is them that's a very small
part of you most of you is in the
unconscious realm it's doing it it's
doing all the heavy lifting a lot of the
decisions you do a lot of the decisions
you think you are making are being made
for you by other [ __ ] routines
running in the background
yeah and they know more than you well
yeah because that and the reason that
why you think that it's you is because
all this [ __ ] happened so quickly and
then your conscious mind sort of also
again very quickly sort of makes a
narrative out of why you decided why you
decided right but usually the narrative
you've invented is not the true motive
your subconscious or your unconscious is
sitting there hiding the facts from you
about yourself yeah so you feel better
about it which is pretty freaky when you
think about it that like you have all
kind of little grimmer on your brain
like doing this [ __ ] well I'm kind of
Persons corpus callosum which haven't
been done in a long time but used to do
people who had bad epileptic yes and it
isolates the left and right hemisphere
of the brain you will be two different
people with two different abilities yeah
you're [ __ ] your I'll be doing some
[ __ ] that you do this other hand didn't
know about yeah and then one side of the
brain will [ __ ] answer a question
totally in opposition to the other one
so when you when you're thinking you
have kind of like this internal dialogue
in your head and like a conversation
going on you it's between all those
second hemispheres yeah that's two
hemispheres and they're arguing most of
the time that's kind of like what was
that one wasn't there Atlit there was
like a little kids movie where there was
like little there was five little
gremlins or little monsters that they
were like different emotions and stuff
and they were living inside this kid's
head and they were always like but yeah
so you want to wrap it up for the window
it's gonna say something about pk
psychokinesis you know I mean the
average kind of the average concept is
to somehow a person is in emanating a
physical force that can move an object I
don't think that's what it is at all
whatever does it back in your
unconscious is having
it's happening in a quantum world it's a
part of quantum computation it's not
dealing with physical matters dealing
with [ __ ] quantum particles quantum
particles can are attached to matter so
it's a mind over matter thing because
the location of an object changed in
your mind in certain circumstances it
changes that object changes its location
in reality because evidently matter as
you know it is not as real as you think
it is once you get down into that
quantum level it's more like a
holographic universe it so the solid
matter is only solid from a certain
point of view and there are other I
guess you could say there are other
versions of you or other unconscious
processes happening inside your brain
that are happening outside the physical
realm I guess be a good way to put it
would be another way to describe it and
and I don't know I can't I can't guess I
can't really put it to words it's some
of the stuff that's happening in your
right hemisphere have a lot to do with
spatial awareness and and that seems to
be the hemisphere where it's coming from
there must be some part of you in the
right hemisphere that knows that
three-dimensional space isn't really
three-dimensional that they're higher
dimensions to it and that matter isn't
really as solid as you think it is and
somehow by changing its perception you
can change reality as you know it which
that sounds [ __ ] bizarre but I think
that's what it is well yeah I mean how
do you explain it that [ __ ] moved yeah
did you see any rays come out of meteors
or you see me exerting the effort there
was no well that's what was strange
about it was that it almost seemed I
don't really want to use the word
mundane but that's kind of how it came
across yeah you know what I mean where
it was just kind of there was nothing
like magical about anything like that
just all of a sudden this [ __ ] was
flying through there yeah there's no
effort or no energy expended yeah so
where did it come from it came from some
kind of weird way of looking at things
more than anything else yeah it wasn't a
physical it wasn't any physical energy
that did it it's outside on our
understanding yeah it's like it's in one
of those little dimensions yeah it's
like right here it is not neutral it's
not but that's not Newtonian physics at
all yeah and somehow it happens through
an altered state of mind did it which
that's some bizarre [ __ ] if you ask me
some of this technology
evidently is extraterrestrial that it's
air force sees whatever whatever made
those understands about this they must
be using that that come that type of
physics yeah where you have objects
accelerate so quick and just do right
angle turns or just vanish yeah no yeah
maybe to them it seems really easy and
today I'm it's something that's easy
because they're technologies based
around what I'm talking about
yeah it's cheating is me not really
right it's making matter matter mass and
energy irrelevant yeah there's a way to
do it to make that irrelevant in other
words to kind of like neuter mass to
make it mass weightless yeah ya know so
you know you can move like a tanker
truck as easily as you can move a cab
exactly so or you can make something
here in another location over there
without having a Trent traverse it right
you just change its location by not
moving it yeah because you've made
space-time irrelevant you made mass and
energy irrelevant because I think mass
and energy and space-time was just
certain manifestations of something
maybe these quantum particles so if
you're dealing with the quantum
particles you know directly you don't
have to go through all this [ __ ] about
mass and energy not the middleman
cutting out the middleman and it must
have something to do with consciousness
because we don't really know what
consciousness is or what consciousness
is made out of you know yeah this one
off on a really deep yeah yeah they're
gonna love this show
I mean if I don't even remember how we
got on that - oh because somebody
requested that we do black monk um which
like I said I'll have to look I we might
have mentioned on another show maybe
you're confusing it like I said with the
black mausoleum haunting I mean I
remember that I wrote about the black
monk of Pontefract in my book but I
don't remember if I did if we did a show
about it or not I don't know because
some people have said they want us to do
like more paranormal stuff like we used
to
yeah but like I said you know 99% of the
recommendations I get her for a
true-crime okay yeah so I'm just trying
to bigger audience but we do need to do
some paranormal stuff we can yeah well I
can read in there for the next couple
weeks all okay I'll work then go back
into Bernal go back into it all right so
you want to wrap this up for Wednesday
yeah you just did okay wrap it [ __ ] like
share subscribe yeah you get us up on
patreon yeah and we still got to do the
YouTube membership to it yeah make it
look good - that one of these days great
so we'll talk to you guys again tomorrow